addiction is not a failure of will
it is a brain disorder which is preyed
upon by the gambling industry so i'm
going into my twitter account and i
start seeing these gambling ads
200 instantly just spent five bucks with
some prominent figures like he one of
the muslims that read the back of
packets you know what i'm talking about
like you're like hey man you want a
starburst here let me see the packet
give it to me let me see it
[Applause]
read that look that's pork right there
one of which is kevin hart okay you
ready oh god we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all salaam
alaikum brothers and sisters we went to
the streets to ask americans about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam
not really do you know anything about
islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that they're out to
kill us all
that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
center the first mega dawah center in
america we have five hundred thousand
dollars left and we need your help to
finish click to donate right now may god
almighty allah reward all of you
now who's kevin hart you are a huge name
probably the biggest name in comedy
right now and you can have a private
island to hang out on but also wonderboy
thomas when you sign up that five
dollars to get 200
in free bets instantly and i start
thinking hasn't kevin hart made enough
money that he doesn't have to go and get
in bed the company doesn't care about
people an industry a company that's
rotten to the core ruining people's
lives i'm still paying for this a piece
of papers that destroy my family
destroying families is rotten to the
core rotten to the core i mean not too
long ago kevin hart did have a
near-death experience where he almost
lost his life he came very close to
death
coming guys don't worry
these are the emergency calls made
moments after kevin hart's vintage
muscle car careened off an la road and
he was very thankful to god i'm thankful
for god
thank you for life it was interesting
the way he was thinking and talking
after this very very close
encounter with death basically would you
realize that you're not in control when
god talks you gotta listen
in
for the first time since this terrifying
accident and frantic 911. now hopefully
kevin hart will see this and he'll have
a change of heart and he'll leave off
his connection with the gambling
industry it ruins people's lives it
takes their money it ruins their
families and maybe after he
has a look at what habib has to say and
that's what motivated me to go and talk
about this is when i saw the stance and
we commend our brother
who has the opportunity to make
habib talks about and kevin hart can
take a lesson when habib talks about how
gambling is more dangerous than alcohol
yesterday
where he talks about how bookmakers
these gambling industries how they ruin
families
how people can go ahead and see kevin
hart the fans of kevin hart and they'll
go click on this ad this gambling ad
200 instantly
just spend five bucks they'll take his
advice because that's what they use
kevin hart for and these others like
wonderboy when you sign up that five
dollars to get two hundred dollars in
free bets instantly and so many other
these athletes and these people are
thinking once you become addicted it's
very very hard to stop because
you have turned you've changed your
brain addiction is a it is a brain that
has changed to become
entrained to the desires of the of the
gambling they're just thinking about the
dollar worshiping the money
even though they got so much money they
just want more and then not thinking
about the consequences the ramifications
of this
my family
cannot live here
i'm still paying for this so people end
up going to these sites and then there's
the start of the addiction parts of the
brain get turned on and then they can't
stop and we think there's probably a
chemical basis to that and you got not
only that person's life gets destroyed
but their whole family gets ruined i was
hiding the tickets from my family and i
was so addicted to gambling that it took
over my life and khabib compares it to a
drug addiction and he's right
to platform
[Music]
comparing at the same level gambling and
drug addiction being at the same level
and gambling kevin hart and many of
these other celebrities out there they
can take a deep lesson from this example
of habibi
so you gotta ask yourself kevin hart
wonderboy and all these others who are
200 instantly
just spend five bucks getting offered
probably big sums of money to go ahead
and promote
these gambling industries is it worth it
at the end and virtually deliberately
harm people if you have a conscious if
it hasn't been that corrupted and
tainted do you want to help ruin
people's lives ruin people's families he
knew what he was doing was destroying
himself and his family connecting with
industries who are rotten to the core
rotten to the core and god willing this
can be a motivation because if you see
other people
at the same level of your status or even
bigger
like habib talking about this taking a
stand god willing the good and you can
come out and you can also take a stand
to get away from the alcohol to get away
from the gambling and all these things
that are destroying society destroying
individuals destroying homes and then
you can go ahead and do something even
more courageous and more bold you can go
ahead and go deeper and to see why is
habib talking like this where is he
getting the backbone where is he getting
the strength it's his connection to his
deen his way of life and you can look
into that way of life and look at all
the proofs and evidence that it provides
the human being to know that it is
indeed the truth and you can start
searching also for the purpose of life
and we'll get you a gift to make things
easy a free copy of the verbatim word of
god almighty the quran go ahead and
visit thedeanshow.com we can send that
out to you as a gift to you and i hope
this message can reach
people like kevin hart and others that
can go ahead and think before they act
and they get tempted and they sell
themselves out for the dollar for the
money so they can go ahead and help
impact lives for the better
do things that will help society not
destroy society like alcohol and in this
case gambling thank you guys for tuning
in subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification bell and do not forget
to support us with the dean center
project where we take the dean show into
the dean center
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum we've
been told that they're out to kill us
all salaam alaikum brothers and sisters
we went to the streets to ask americans
about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam
not really do you know anything about
islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that uh they're out
to kill us all
that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
center the first mega dawah center in
america we have five hundred thousand
dollars left and we need your help to
finish click to donate right now may god
almighty allah reward all of you
i cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the quran go and visit
thedeenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum